grab some tissues this is good mark
wahlberg appears on the talk this friday
at 2 p.m eastern on global and opens up
about filming his latest project father
stu in the midst of his mother's passing
yeah mark went back and forth to visit
his mom alma during the filming but was
on set in april of 2021 when he learned
that she had died at 78 following a
battle with dementia but keeping things
positive mark is all about celebrating
and remembering all the good times take
a look we'll see you back here next time
bye it's one of those things where she
was not well and i knew that you know um
her time was limited and so it was kind
of going back and forth between and
found out literally on the set
that she had finally passed and i've
always kind of used all my real life
experience the good stuff the bad stuff
to draw on and trying to play
the roles in the most authentic and
believable ways but with that particular
see there's a moment when i'm in the
church and i'm kind of asking why
and um you know that was kind of like
right after i had found out and so
yeah i kind of always just go there
anyway i want to spend so much more time
celebrating remembering all the good
times and all the good that she did as
opposed to the suffering yeah it's just
you know it's just uh unfortunate timing
was never a good time for something like
that but uh she's definitely in a better
place and she also likes to she dealt
with it with such grace and dignity um
and it really kind of helped us to kind
of deal with what was happening